Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply.
您的夏天从家得宝（Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销活动开始。是时候用下一款烧烤架——四头燃气烧烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需199美元。整个季节都可以用Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅来招待亲友，仅需49美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期至5月14日或5月27日。仅限美国，受条款限制。
See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. With phrases like, what a bird brain, or that's for the birds, the English language doesn't offer much respect to avian species. But for decades, researchers have known that some birds are more intelligent than they're usually given credit for. From parrots that can communicate with words to crows that use tools, psychologists and other researchers have found that birds can be as smart as primates, or even in some cases human children. Today we're going to talk to one of the world's leading experts on bird cognition and communication about how birds think, the extent of their intelligence, what they can do that might surprise you, and what they can teach us about intelligence
详情请见Home Depot.com斜杠price match。像“鸟脑子”或“那是给鸟准备的”这类短语，英语语言对鸟类并没有表现出多少尊重。但几十年来，研究人员一直知道，一些鸟类的智力比人们通常认为的要高。从能用词汇交流的鹦鹉到会使用工具的乌鸦，心理学家和其他研究人员发现，鸟类的聪明程度可以媲美灵长类动物，在某些情况下甚至能达到人类儿童的水平。今天，我们将与世界领先的鸟类认知与交流专家之一探讨鸟类是如何思考的、它们智力的广度、它们可能让你感到惊讶的能力，以及它们能教给我们关于智力的什么知识。
in general. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Irene Pepperberg, an adjunct research professor at Boston University in Boston, Massachusetts. She spent nearly five decades working with gray parrots, training them to communicate in English and studying their intelligence. Her research has found that great parrots are in some areas as intelligent as five or six-year-old children. Her most famous work was with a parrot named Alex, who died in 2007. Today she runs the Alex Foundation, which supports her continuing research. She's also held many academic appointments, including at Harvard University, Brandeis University, and MIT's Media Lab.
总的来说。欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是波士顿大学的兼职研究教授艾琳·佩珀伯格博士。她在波士顿马萨诸塞州工作了近五十年，研究灰鹦鹉，训练它们用英语交流并研究它们的智力。她的研究发现，灰鹦鹉在某些领域的智力相当于五六岁的儿童。她最著名的研究对象是一只名叫亚历克斯的鹦鹉，它于2007年去世。今天，她经营着亚历克斯基金会，支持她持续的研究。她还担任过许多学术职务，包括在哈佛大学、布兰迪斯大学和麻省理工学院媒体实验室。
She's authored more than 100 academic publications and two books, including the memoir, Alex and me. Her life and work were recently the subject of a play called Beyond Words, performed in Boston last spring. Dr. Pepperberg, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me. One detail I didn't mention from your biography is that your PhD is actually in chemical physics, not in psychology or animal behavior. So why don't you start by telling us about how your career with the birds started? What sparked your interest? And how did you decide to make this big switch?
她撰写了100多篇学术论文和两本书，包括回忆录《亚历克斯和我》。她的生活和工作最近成为了波士顿去年春天上演的一部名为《超越言语》的戏剧的主题。佩珀伯格博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。您简历中我没提到的一个细节是，您的博士学位实际上是化学物理学，而不是心理学或动物行为学。那么，您为什么不先告诉我们您的鸟类研究生涯是如何开始的呢？是什么激发了您的兴趣？您又是如何决定做出这个重大转变的？
It started actually when I was a young child. I lived above a store in Brooklyn. My father was working full time, going to school and taking care of a sick mother. So I barely saw him. my mother would have been great in my generation. She wanted a career. But in those days, you had a child, you were fired, and you had to stay home. So she took care of my physical but not my emotional needs. And my father bought me a little herakite, a little green budger gar that you would get at what the stores then were Woolworths. And that bird was my constant companion. And I think I must have imprinted on this little budgey. So we fast forward. I was very good in chemistry. I was getting my doctor. and Harvard, and I was rather disillusioned at that point. It was, unfortunately, a very sexist atmosphere. We were told that, you know, there was no way we'd ever get a job at a place like Harvard, because they would never hire a woman because we weren't good enough. And we sat there saying,
其实这始于我还是个孩子的时候。我住在布鲁克林一家商店的楼上。我父亲全职工作，还要上学并照顾生病的母亲。所以我几乎见不到他。我母亲如果生在我这一代会很出色。她想要一份事业。但在那个年代，你一旦有了孩子就会被解雇，必须待在家里。所以她照顾了我的生理需求，但没有照顾我的情感需求。我父亲给我买了一只小虎皮鹦鹉，就是那种你在当时的伍尔沃斯商店能买到的绿色小鹦鹉。那只鸟是我忠实的伙伴。我想我一定是对这只小虎皮鹦鹉产生了印记。快进到后来，我化学学得很好。我正在哈佛攻读博士学位，当时我感到相当幻灭。不幸的是，那是一个非常性别歧视的环境。我们被告知，你知道，我们永远不可能在哈佛这样的地方找到工作，因为他们永远不会雇佣女性，因为我们不够好。我们坐在那里说，
but you're giving us PhDs, don't you think that's good enough? And the answer was no. I also realized, and this was even more important, I was doing a mathematical modeling of reaction rates and chemical structures, and it was taking me seven years, and I realized that the way computers were going, that in, you know, a while it wouldn't take someone seven years, but it would take them seven minutes. Of course, now it's seven nanoseconds, actually, and I just didn't see any future in this. And at the same time, my then-hundred husband and I were, had been living in an apartment in Cambridge that was set on fire by an arsonist. We ended up moving into his post-doctoral advisor's house because his advisor had just
但你们给了我们博士学位，难道你们不认为这足够好了吗？答案是否定的。我还意识到，这一点更为重要，我当时正在对反应速率和化学结构进行数学建模，这花了我七年时间，我意识到随着计算机的发展，在不久的将来，这不会花某人七年时间，而只需要七分钟。当然，现在实际上只需要七纳秒，我只是没看到这行有什么前途。与此同时，我和我当时的丈夫住在剑桥的一间公寓里，被一个纵火犯放火烧了。我们最终搬进了他博士后导师的家里，因为他的导师刚刚
gotten a divorce and had two young children. He needed help with the kids. We needed a place to live, so we became kind of au pairs. And we used to babysit for the children, not very often, but just enough. and we would always try to do things like educational TV such as Nova programs, and this is leading somewhere, because the Nova programs at that point were on things like why do birds sing and the signing chimps and the computer using chimps and the dolphin language work. And I went thinking to myself, I love animals. I had a budgie that talked. Why aren't they using parrots for this type of work?
离婚了，有两个年幼的孩子。他需要人帮忙照顾孩子。我们需要一个住的地方，所以我们成了某种互惠生。我们过去常帮他们照看孩子，次数不多，但刚好够用。我们总是尝试做一些像Nova节目那样的教育电视节目，这事儿是有原因的，因为当时的Nova节目内容是关于鸟类为什么唱歌、会手语的黑猩猩、会使用计算机的黑猩猩以及海豚语言研究。我心想，我爱动物。我有一只会说话的虎皮鹦鹉。为什么他们不利用鹦鹉进行这类研究呢？
So I went over to the Museum of Comparative Zoology. I said to them that I wanted to switch fields. They said, no, no, no, you're ABD. Just finished the doctor. It's a union card. But you can sit in on any of my courses. You know, we don't care. So they said, just don't make us grade your papers.
所以我去了比较动物学博物馆。我告诉他们我想转行。他们说，不，不，不，你还没拿到博士学位。先把博士读完。那是一张工会卡。但你可以旁听我的任何课程。你知道，我们不在乎。所以他们说，只要别让我们批改你的作业就行。
And I said, fine. So I, and I cut the same deal with the psychology department. And so I was going to all these incredible seminars on animal behavior and child language acquisition, which was also in its infancy at that point. People were just beginning to figure out how children learned to speak. So there was this plethora of just amazing research that I could immerse myself in. So I spent 40 hours a week finishing the doctorate and 40 hours a week doing all this other stuff. And that's, you know, that's how I started the switch in fields.
我说，好吧。于是，我和心理学系达成了同样的协议。所以我参加了所有这些关于动物行为和儿童语言习得的精彩研讨会，当时这门学科也处于起步阶段。人们才刚刚开始弄清楚儿童是如何学会说话的。所以有大量令人惊叹的研究让我可以沉浸其中。所以我每周花40小时完成博士学位，每周花40小时做所有这些其他事情。这就是，你知道，我如何开始转行的。
Can you tell our listeners more about what it means when people say parrots are as intelligent as a five or six-year-old child. In what ways are they smart? What kinds of things that can they do that might surprise people? Well, there are a bunch of studies that have been done with children, particularly ones by the Swiss psychologist Piersier. People may have heard of him. He studied child development and child psychology. And he came up with a list of types of tests that you would give children at different stages in their development. And we've given the same type of. of tasks to our birds. So one such task, it's everybody probably knows the task. They probably haven't known that it was Piaget, but you take two glasses of water, they're half full, glasses
您能告诉我们的听众，当人们说鹦鹉的智力相当于五六岁儿童时，这意味着什么吗？它们在哪些方面聪明？它们能做哪些可能会让人们感到惊讶的事情？嗯，已经有很多针对儿童的研究，特别是瑞士心理学家皮亚杰的研究。人们可能听说过他。他研究儿童发展和儿童心理学。他列出了一系列在儿童发展的不同阶段会给他们做的测试。我们也给我们的鸟类做了同样类型的任务。所以其中一项任务，每个人可能都知道这个任务。他们可能不知道这是皮亚杰提出的，但你拿两个半满的玻璃杯，其实是
of juice actually, that they're half full, and you give it to the child and you say, which one do you want? And they giggle, you know, whatever age they are, they giggle and they say, it doesn't matter. Then you pour one into a tall, thin glass and one into a short fat glass. And then you give it to the child and say which one do you want? If the child is under about five years old, they'll generally point to the tall, thin one and say that one. And you say, why? And they say, because there's more. And you say, but you just told me it was the same. Well, now there's more. Okay. No conservation of material. If you ask a six-year-old child, they may point to the same glass, but then you ask them why, and they'll say, oh, because it looks like it's more fun to drink out of.
果汁杯，它们是半满的，你把它们给孩子，然后问，你想要哪一个？他们会咯咯笑，你知道，无论他们多大，他们会咯咯笑并说，没关系。然后你把其中一杯倒进一个又高又细的玻璃杯里，另一杯倒进一个又矮又胖的玻璃杯里。然后你把它们给孩子并问你想要哪一个？如果孩子不到五岁左右，他们通常会指着那个又高又细的杯子说那个。你问为什么？他们说，因为那个更多。你说，但你刚才告诉我它们是一样的。嗯，现在那个更多了。好吧。没有物质守恒概念。如果你问一个六岁的孩子，他们可能会指着同一个杯子，但当你问他们为什么时，他们会说，哦，因为看起来用那个喝更有趣。
They know it's the same amount of liquid, but you ask them to choose and they come up with a reasonable explanation. Well, we gave this type of task to our birds, and they pass. We gave them another Peugeetian task on probability. So this is, again, another fun one, very simple. You have a bucket. You put three blue marbles in and one red marble in and you mix it up. It's an opaque bucket. And then you take out one marble. The child doesn't know which marble it is in your hand and you ask the child, what do you think, what color do you think it is? And if the child is, again, four years old or so, they'll say, oh, because red's my favorite color, so it's red. Or they'll say, well, you put one red one in and you took one thing out, so it has to be red.
他们知道液体量是一样的，但你让他们选择时，他们会给出一个合理的解释。嗯，我们给我们的鸟类做了这类任务，它们通过了。我们给它们做了另一个关于概率的皮亚杰式任务。所以这又是另一个有趣的、非常简单的任务。你有一个桶。你放入三个蓝色弹珠和一个红色弹珠，然后混合起来。这是一个不透明的桶。然后你拿出一个弹珠。孩子不知道你手里的是哪个弹珠，你问孩子，你认为，你认为它是什么颜色的？如果孩子，同样是四岁左右，他们会说，哦，因为红色是我最喜欢的颜色，所以它是红色的。或者他们会说，嗯，你放了一个红色的进去，你拿出了一个东西，所以它一定是红色的。
There's some logic, but it's not the right one. You ask a six-year-old child, and they'll say blue, and you say, why? Well, you put more blue in, so it's more likely to be blue. And we gave that type of test to my parrots, and again, they passed. Now, how do you translate that test to a parrot? You ask him. Yes, I mean, our parrots talk. So the parrot says blue. Exactly.
这有一定的逻辑，但不是正确的逻辑。你问一个六岁的孩子，他们会说蓝色，你问为什么？嗯，你放进去的蓝色更多，所以它更有可能是蓝色的。我们给我的鹦鹉做了那种测试，它们又通过了。那么，你如何把那个测试翻译给鹦鹉呢？你问它。是的，我的意思是，我们的鹦鹉会说话。所以鹦鹉说蓝色。完全正确。
Or actually with our birds, we asked how different, different objects. So it was pieces of paper and keys or pieces of wood and corks. And we mixed all the different combinations so they couldn't say the same thing all the time because we had we had one bird, so we had to ask him 96 times. Pioge asked the children once or twice. But yes, he would, you know, he'd say, what do you think is in here? And he couldn't possibly know, but he'd have to make an assumption as to what it was. And we picked this, the larger number, the larger amount, 75% of the time and the smaller one, 25% of the time. So he tracked the probabilities. Now, how did you end up with Alex and why go with a gray parrot?
或者实际上对于我们的鸟，我们问的是不同物体之间的区别。所以是纸片和钥匙，或者是木块和软木塞。我们混合了所有不同的组合，这样它们就不能总是说同样的话，因为我们只有一只鸟，所以我们不得不问它96次。皮亚杰问孩子们一两次。但是的，他会，你知道，他会说，你认为这里面是什么？他不可能知道，但他必须做出假设。我们选择了这个，较大数量的，75%的时间，较小数量的，25%的时间。所以它追踪了概率。那么，你是怎么得到亚历克斯的，为什么选择灰鹦鹉？
among all the birds that are available in the world. It's easier to ask you a second question. The reason I chose a great parrot is, first of all, they are the clearest talkers of all of the parrots. They have a slightly different muscular system that allows them to talk more clearly. And second, there had been work in Germany by a professor Otto Curler on number concepts in gray parrots. So he already had shown that these birds were quite smart. They can actually identify sets of numbers up to about six or eight. I can't remember which one he was working on, but six or eight.
在世界上所有可用的鸟类中。回答你的第二个问题更容易。我选择灰鹦鹉的原因是，首先，它们是所有鹦鹉中说话最清晰的。它们有稍微不同的肌肉系统，使它们能说得更清楚。其次，德国的奥托·库勒教授在灰鹦鹉的数字概念方面做过研究。所以他已经证明这些鸟非常聪明。它们实际上可以识别多达六或八个数字的集合。我不记得他当时在研究哪一个了，但六或八。
So there was some evidence that I could write when I was putting in a grant proposal to say, these are smart birds. Alex was a random choice. We had gone to a lot of different pet stores. We finally found one that had birds that had been raised in the States. We didn't want a wild-caught bird for a lot of reasons. I mean, it's just a horrible thing to decimate the wild population. And there were a cage of eight birds, and I asked the fellow to pick one out just randomly,
所以有一些证据可以让我写拨款申请书时说，这些是聪明的鸟。亚历克斯是一个随机的选择。我们去了很多不同的宠物店。我们终于找到了一家有在美国本土繁育的鸟的店。出于很多原因，我们不想要野外捕获的鸟。我的意思是，摧毁野生种群是一件可怕的事情。那里有一个装有八只鸟的笼子，我让那个人随机挑一只，
because I didn't know anything, and I didn't want anybody to think that I chose in a special bird. So he just took a butterfly net, scooped one up, you know, got it out, flipped it on it back, clipped its wings, it shows, speaks it here. Now, you taught Alex more than 150 English labels to describe objects, colors, numbers, numbers and other things, but you always use the word labels rather than language when you talk about communicating with parrots. Why is that? Well, language is very special. I know I have a lot of colleagues who talk about ape language or, you know, whale language and things like that. We don't yet understand the complexities of their communication system. We do know a lot about ours,
因为我什么都不知道，我不想让任何人认为我挑选了一只特别的鸟。所以他只是拿了一个蝴蝶网，舀起一只，你知道，把它弄出来，翻过身，剪掉它的翅膀，它展示，在这里说话。现在，你教了亚历克斯超过150个英语标签来描述物体、颜色、数字和其他东西，但当你谈论与鹦鹉交流时，你总是使用“标签”这个词而不是“语言”。为什么呢？嗯，语言是非常特殊的。我知道我有很多同事谈论猿类语言或，你知道，鲸鱼语言之类的东西。我们还不了解它们交流系统的复杂性。我们确实很了解我们自己的，
and ours is so much more complex than we have ever been able to teach a non-human. So you and I can talk about anything. We can talk about things that don't exist, okay? We can talk about the future, we can talk about the past. No matter how long we will have trained any of these animals, they are not using our speech patterns or our signs, if they're using sign language,
而我们的语言比我们能够教给任何非人类物种的要复杂得多。所以你和我可以谈论任何事情。我们可以谈论不存在的事情，好吗？我们可以谈论未来，我们可以谈论过去。无论我们训练这些动物多久，它们都不会使用我们的语音模式或我们的手势，如果它们使用手语的话，
or our plastic chips or computer symbols, they're not using them in those types of complex ways. It's definitely interspecies communication. I mean, we are communicating with them, just not at the same level. So I'm very careful to make that distinction. The animals have their own separate communication system, which might be much more complex than we understand.
或者我们的塑料筹码或计算机符号，它们不会以那些复杂的方式使用它们。这绝对是跨物种交流。我的意思是，我们正在与它们交流，只是不在同一个水平上。所以我非常小心地做出这种区分。动物有它们自己独立的交流系统，这可能比我们理解的要复杂得多。
We are actually asking them to learn a second language. Now, think about that. You know, we have been too stupid to crack their codes, but we're asking them to learn our code. So, you know, I'll leave it at that. Now, you've also done some experiments that look at how well parrots do on the famous marshmallow test, which looks at how well a child, or in this case, a bird, can wait for a reward. How do parrots compare with children on that test?
我们实际上是在要求它们学习第二语言。现在，想想看。你知道，我们太笨了，无法破解它们的密码，但我们却要求它们学习我们的密码。所以，你知道，我就说到这里。现在，你也做了一些实验，观察鹦鹉在著名的棉花糖测试中的表现，该测试观察孩子，或者在这种情况下，鸟类，能等待奖励多久。鹦鹉在这个测试中与孩子相比如何？
They are almost identical. Not only could our bird Griffin wait for 15 minutes for a better reward or, or more reward, but to distract himself during the waiting period, he engaged in the same types of behaviors that the children did. He would sing to himself, he would turn around and preen, he would fall asleep. I mean, we actually have a little video, split-screen video, of some children whose videos we've taken off YouTube and the same behavior in our bird while he's waiting. And you've looked at bird's mathematical abilities, which includes their ability to recognize numbers and grasp the concept of zero. Can you talk about that? How does a bird understand zero?
它们几乎是一模一样的。我们的鸟格里芬不仅能等待15分钟以获得更好的奖励或更多的奖励，而且为了在等待期间分散自己的注意力，它还表现出了与孩子们相同的行为。它会对自己唱歌，它会转过身梳理羽毛，它会睡着。我的意思是，我们实际上有一个小视频，分屏视频，是一些我们从YouTube上下载的孩子们的视频，以及我们的鸟在等待时表现出的相同行为。你研究了鸟类的数学能力，包括它们识别数字和掌握零概念的能力。你能谈谈那个吗？鸟是如何理解零的？
Well, I called it a zero-like concept because it wasn't exactly zero. He died before we could teach him enough to see if it really was zero. But what happened was we had trained him to identify sets of objects. So he could look at a set of mixed objects, blue and red balls and blocks all mixed in, and I could say, what color blue block? And he could tell me up to six at that point. We then did comprehension studies where we'd put mixes of different colors sets and say what color is six, so we'd have to find the six in the set and tell us the color. We also later trained him, so he understood up to eight as an exact number. But when we were doing the comprehension study, he was completely bored because he had been doing numbers for so long at this point.
嗯，我称之为类零概念，因为它并不完全是零。它在去世前我们还没能教它足够多来确定它是否真的是零。但发生的情况是，我们已经训练它识别物体集合。所以它可以看一组混合的物体，蓝色和红色的球和积木混在一起，我可以问，什么颜色的蓝色积木？它当时能告诉我多达六个。然后我们做了理解研究，我们放入不同颜色的混合集合并说六是什么颜色，所以它必须在集合中找到六并告诉我们颜色。我们后来还训练了它，所以它理解多达八作为一个确切的数字。但当我们做理解研究时，它完全厌倦了，因为它当时做数字任务已经太久了。
And we had to ask him like 60 trials to get statistical significance. So he did the first 12 trials absolutely perfectly. And then we start giving him the sets and he looks at the things on the tray and he takes his beak and he knocks them all off. Or he turns around and he starts preening. Or the worst case scenario is he look at the, blocks and if they were like yellow, green, and blue, I'd say, what color six? And it tells me orange, purple, all the colors that were not on the tray. So this was getting rather
我们不得不问它大约60次试验才能获得统计学意义。所以它前12次试验做得绝对完美。然后我们开始给它集合，它看着托盘上的东西，它用喙把它们全部撞掉。或者它转过身开始梳理羽毛。或者最坏的情况是，它看着积木，如果它们是黄色的、绿色的和蓝色的，我会问，六是什么颜色？它告诉我橙色、紫色，所有不在托盘上的颜色。所以这变得相当
frustrating. We switched to using things like jelly beans, which he really liked and he could have a jelly bean if he was correct. It was still really tough going, but we were being in except data. And then one day I walk in with sets and I have three, four, and six things on the tray. And I say, Alex, what color three? And he looks at me and he goes, five. And they go, what color three? Because there's no five things on the tray. So what color three? Five. We go back and forth a couple of times. So he's not throwing things on the floor. He's not giving me all the wrong colors. He's not ignoring me. So I look at him just, I mean, all right, smarty, what color five? You know, thinking, whatever. And he looks at me and he goes none. Now he had learned none
令人沮丧。我们改用像软糖豆这样的东西，它真的很喜欢，如果它答对了，它就能得到一颗软糖豆。这仍然非常艰难，但我们正在获取数据。然后有一天，我带着集合走进去，托盘上有三个、四个和六个东西。我说，亚历克斯，三是什么颜色？它看着我，然后说，五。我说，三是什么颜色？因为托盘上没有五个东西。所以三是什么颜色？五。我们来回了几次。所以它没有把东西扔在地板上。它没有给我所有错误的颜色。它没有忽视我。所以我看着它，我的意思是，好吧，聪明鬼，五是什么颜色？你知道，心想，随便吧。它看着我，然后说没有。现在它已经学会了“没有”
in response to the absence of attributes on the task of same and different. So we could show him two things and ask what's same and what's different. And he'd say color, shape, matter or none if nothing were same or different. So here he transferred the concept of the absence of an attribute to the absence of the set. And we were able to test that out, and that was solid. But if we gave him like nothing on the tray and said, you know, what's there, he didn't say none. He didn't quite make the transfer. Because we had never trained him to use that in, you know, to total absence of everything.
作为对“相同和不同”任务中属性缺失的回应。所以我们可以给它看两个东西并问什么是相同的，什么是不同的。它会说颜色、形状、材质，或者如果没有任何东西相同或不同，它会说没有。所以在这里，它将属性缺失的概念转移到了集合缺失上。我们能够测试这一点，而且结果很可靠。但如果我们给它托盘上什么都没有，并说，你知道，那里有什么，它没有说没有。它没有完全完成这种转移。因为我们从未训练过它在，你知道，完全没有任何东西的情况下使用那个词。
So that's where we were when he passed away. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room.
所以这就是它去世时我们的研究进度。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到台阶。我们省了多少钱？足够了。足够迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。
Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. I know you've done your work with parrots, but are other birds as smart as parrots or are they just intelligent in different ways? Most of them have been tested in different ways.
距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在Hilton.com或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可节省20%，获得您期待的住宿体验。当您想要节省开支，而不是惊喜时。您住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为您提供住宿。我知道您对鹦鹉做了研究，但其他鸟类也像鹦鹉一样聪明吗？还是它们以不同的方式聪明？它们中的大多数已经在不同的方式下进行了测试。
So you have the tool using cockatoos, which are incredibly amazing. you can give them a box that needs six different, I think five or six different types of latches and screws and things to manipulate to open the box and they'll figure out how to do it. Okay? You've got the tool making crows. You've got a lot of different work with these different birds. So there was crows that would do the Aesop's Fable Task where it would learn to drop stones into a dish of water until the water was high enough so it could take the seed off the top of the water.
所以你有会使用工具的凤头鹦鹉，它们非常令人惊叹。你可以给它们一个盒子，需要六种，我想是五或六种不同类型的锁扣和螺丝以及其他东西来操作才能打开盒子，它们会弄清楚怎么做。好吗？你有会制造工具的乌鸦。你有很多关于这些不同鸟类的不同研究。所以有乌鸦会做伊索寓言任务，它会学会把石头扔进水盘里，直到水位足够高，这样它就能从水面上拿到种子。
So they've all been tested on different types of tasks. And, you know, it would be really interesting at some point for us to, you know, get together and do similar types of tasks. But grays are really bad at tool use. You know, their attitude is, hey, I've got a Swiss Army night on the front of my beak and, you know, that's all I need. It's good enough. And that's good enough, yeah. Is there a connection between birds' song and the speech of parrots? And do birds learn to sing the same way that parrots learn words?
所以它们都在不同类型的任务上进行了测试。而且，你知道，在某个时候我们聚在一起做类似的任务会非常有趣。但灰鹦鹉在工具使用方面真的很差。你知道，它们的态度是，嘿，我的喙前面有一把瑞士军刀，你知道，这就是我所需要的。这就足够了。而且这就足够了，是的。鸟类的鸣叫和鹦鹉的说话之间有联系吗？鸟类学习鸣叫的方式和鹦鹉学习单词的方式一样吗？
Oh, that is a good question. We don't know for sure, but we do know that the brain structures are very similar in songbirds and in parrots. And in humans, in fact, there are seven structures in all of those. brains that seem to be responsible for vocal learning. So they're arranged in slightly different ways and they're connected pretty much the same way, though. What is interesting is the parents like Alex have another shell, it's called, and that is the thickness of that area seems to be related to the ease at which these birds learn their non-species-specific vocalizations, their ability to say mimic speech.
哦，那是个好问题。我们不能确定，但我们确实知道鸣禽和鹦鹉的大脑结构非常相似。事实上，在人类中，所有这些大脑中都有七个结构似乎负责发声学习。所以它们的排列方式略有不同，但连接方式基本相同。有趣的是，像亚历克斯这样的鹦鹉有另一个壳，它被称为，那个区域的厚度似乎与这些鸟学习非物种特异性发声的难易程度有关，即它们模仿人类语言的能力。
So Akea, which is a very smart parrot, that's another one of these tool using parrots, that's really, really smart, has a very thin shell, and it's not known for mimicking human speech. Grays have a very thick shell, and they're one of the best mimics of human speech. But we do know that those brain structures are pretty much similar across those species. Once in a while, other bird species will learn some words. Is that because they have some physiological difference? I mean, I think you talked about your budgie knowing some words, which is also a parrot. But I think that there have been what starlings that could do a little talking.
所以啄羊鹦鹉，这是一种非常聪明的鹦鹉，是另一种会使用工具的鹦鹉，真的非常非常聪明，它的壳很薄，而且不以模仿人类语言而闻名。灰鹦鹉有一个非常厚的壳，它们是模仿人类语言最好的鸟类之一。但我们确实知道这些大脑结构在这些物种中基本相似。偶尔，其他鸟类也会学习一些单词。这是因为它们有什么生理差异吗？我的意思是，我想你谈到了你的虎皮鹦鹉会一些单词，那也是一种鹦鹉。但我认为有椋鸟也能说一点话。
Yes. And again, it's this song learning mechanism, these seventh areas in the brain that are responsible for the sprocal learning. And we would assume that birds like starlings have may or may not, they haven't been studied yet, have some of this additional shell area that allows for the heterospecific localization. One really fascinating aspect of your work is the relationship that you develop with birds over time. I've heard you describe them as colleagues. Why do you use that term? Tell us more about the relationship that you have with the birds you study.
是的。同样，这是鸣叫学习机制，大脑中负责这种发声学习的七个区域。我们假设像椋鸟这样的鸟类可能，也可能没有，它们还没有被研究过，拥有一些这种额外的壳区域，允许异种发声。你研究的一个非常迷人的方面是你随着时间的推移与鸟类建立的关系。我听过你把它们描述为同事。你为什么使用这个词？告诉我们更多关于你与你研究的鸟类之间的关系。
Yeah, you know, people ask me, well, are they your pets? And the answer is no. You know, are they your subjects? And I have to say that they are much more than subjects because all the work that we do is dependent upon their billing, being willing to work with us. We don't limit their food intake. We don't limit their water intake. We do limit their treat intake. But that's, you know, that's kind of makes more sense. You know, you wouldn't give children cookies all day, right? So the fact is if they want something that the parrot equivalent of a cookie, yes, they have to kind of work with us. But hey, you know, cookies are optional. So the idea is that we try to do things that would intrigue them, would interest them, would get them to want to work with us. And again, you care for your colleagues. People ask me about my emotional bond to the birds. And, you know, I have to have a certain amount of distancing to be able to, you know, look at all the work just passionately and to be able to evaluate it just passionately. But that doesn't
是的，你知道，人们问我，嗯，它们是你的宠物吗？答案是不。你知道，它们是你的实验对象吗？我不得不说它们远不止是实验对象，因为我们所做的所有工作都依赖于它们的意愿，愿意与我们合作。我们不限制它们的食物摄入量。我们不限制它们的饮水摄入量。我们确实限制它们的零食摄入量。但那，你知道，那更有意义。你知道，你不会整天给孩子吃饼干，对吧？所以事实是，如果它们想要某种相当于鹦鹉饼干的东西，是的，它们必须以某种方式与我们合作。但嘿，你知道，饼干是可选的。所以我们的想法是，我们尝试做一些能引起它们兴趣、吸引它们、让它们想要与我们合作的事情。而且，你知道，你关心你的同事。人们问我关于我对鸟类的情感纽带。而且，你知道，我必须保持一定的距离，才能，你知道，客观地看待所有的工作，并能够客观地评估它。但这并不
mean I don't care for them the way you care for a colleague. I mean, you like your colleagues. You'll ask how their weekends were and things like that. But you, you know, you don't cross a certain line with the way you feel about your colleagues. And that's what we had to keep careful with our birds. So we could have, you know, we could care for them. We could have some kind of emotional bond with them, but we had to draw a line as to how far that could go. So you're working with two other grays right now. Is that correct? Can you tell us about those birds? Yeah, there's Griffin, who's 29 years old in Athena, and Griffin is the one that we did in Athena. We worked with the Piagetian studies with them, with the liquid conservation studies with
意味着我不像关心同事那样关心它们。我的意思是，你喜欢你的同事。你会问他们的周末过得怎么样之类的问题。但你，你知道，你不会在对同事的感觉上越过某条界限。这就是我们必须对我们的鸟类保持谨慎的地方。所以我们可以，你知道，我们可以关心它们。我们可以与它们建立某种情感纽带，但我们必须划定界限，说明这种纽带能走多远。所以你现在正在和另外两只灰鹦鹉一起工作。对吗？你能告诉我们关于那些鸟的事吗？是的，有格里芬，它29岁了，还有雅典娜，格里芬就是我们做过雅典娜研究的那只。我们和它们一起做了皮亚杰研究，和它们一起做了液体守恒研究。
them. We did the probability study and the marshmallow study with Griffin. We've been doing some more work with Griffin on visual working memory and another work on something called inference by exclusion, which means figure out where something is by being given information about where it's not. So those are a lot of the studies. We've done a lot of work on optical illusions, first with Alex, but now also with Griffin, and they seem to see them the same way we do. Although the most recent one we're working on, that may not be the case. But we're just beginning to collect date on that. So we really don't know where that's going to lead. Do you see a difference in the intelligence among these three birds in particular or personality? I mean, if you even feel that they
我们和格里芬一起做了概率研究和棉花糖研究。我们一直在和格里芬做更多关于视觉工作记忆的研究，以及关于一种叫做排除推理的研究，这意味着通过被告知某物不在哪里来弄清楚它在哪里。所以这些是很多研究。我们做了很多关于视错觉的研究，最初是和亚历克斯，但现在也和格里芬一起，它们似乎以和我们相同的方式看待它们。虽然我们最近正在研究的一个，情况可能并非如此。但我们才刚刚开始收集相关数据。所以我们真的不知道这会引向何处。你在这三只鸟中特别看到了智力或个性上的差异吗？我的意思是，如果你甚至觉得它们
have personality? Oh, definitely in personality. Alex was incredibly smart and also basically was very eager to learn and eager to test things and see what happened. So it was like with none, He just would, you know, want to push things. Griffin grew up with Alex being his critical, you know, older brother. So, I mean, we, you know, when they're first learning their labels, the labels aren't clear. They won't go and just say green, but they'll go, and, you know, you have to work with them to make clear. So we'd be asking things like Griffin, what color? And he'd go, green.
有性格的话？哦，性格上绝对有。亚历克斯非常聪明，而且基本上非常渴望学习，渴望测试事物并观察会发生什么。所以就像“没有”一样，它只是，你知道，想要推动事情。格里芬是在亚历克斯作为它挑剔的，你知道，哥哥的环境下长大的。所以，我的意思是，我们，你知道，当它们第一次学习标签时，标签不清楚。它们不会去直接说绿色，但它们会去，你知道，你必须与它们合作才能说清楚。所以我们会问像格里芬，什么颜色？它会说，绿色。
And I'd say, no, talk clearly. Say better. Well, we'd ask, you know, Griffin, hey, what color? And Alex would say, no, tell me what shape. And Griffin would look at him, look at me, sure, his little birdie shoulders and go, do I answer? No, do I answer? So Griffin is turned out to be really, also really, really smart,
我会说，不，说清楚。说得更好。嗯，我们会问，你知道，格里芬，嘿，什么颜色？亚历克斯会说，不，告诉我什么形状。格里芬会看着它，看着我，耸耸它的小鸟肩膀，然后说，我回答吗？不，我回答吗？所以格里芬结果证明也非常，非常聪明，
but, you know, tell me, the student who says, tell me what I have to do to get the A. Just show me what I have to do to get the, and I'll do it, and I'll do it in spade. But, you know, I'm not going to try something new because I could make a mistake and I'm going to get yelled at. So in Athena, she can speak very clearly, when she wants to. But her attitude, her very different personality, it's like I said Orange,
但是，你知道，告诉我，那个说，告诉我我必须做什么才能得到A的学生。只要告诉我我必须做什么才能得到，我就会做，而且我会做得非常出色。但是，你知道，我不会尝试新事物，因为我可能会犯错，然后我会挨骂。所以在雅典娜身上，她想说的时候可以说得很清楚。但她的态度，她非常不同的个性，就像我说橙色，
why do I have to say it again? You know I can say it. I know that you know that I know that I can say it. So, you know, we're done. And it's, of course, very frustrating to get statistical significant data from her because of that behavior. Now, that is a criticism that I have heard. Like, how could this be statistically significant? Because you're really only working with a very small number of birds. And what is your answer when other researchers say that to you? Well, I mean, there is basically the idea that if one individual can do this task, and if you document that individuals work very, very carefully, which we have done, then it suggests that the species is capable.
为什么我必须再说一遍？你知道我会说。我知道你知道我知道我会说。所以，你知道，我们完了。而且，当然，因为这种行为，从她那里获得具有统计学意义的数据非常令人沮丧。现在，这是我听到的一种批评。就像，这怎么可能具有统计学意义？因为你实际上只研究了极少数的鸟类。当其他研究人员那样对你说时，你的回答是什么？嗯，我的意思是，基本上有这样一种观点，如果一个个体能完成这个任务，而且如果你非常、非常仔细地记录那个个体的工作，我们已经做到了，那么这表明该物种是有能力的。
It doesn't mean that every member of the species will do it. I mean, like Athena, you know, I'm not sure how much data we're going to get from her, okay? But, you know, from Griffin and Alex, you see that. It's like looking at humans. We say that humans, humans are brilliant. We have Einstein. We have Beethoven. We have Picasso.
这并不意味着该物种的每个成员都会这样做。我的意思是，像雅典娜，你知道，我不确定我们能从她那里得到多少数据，好吗？但是，你知道，从格里芬和亚历克斯那里，你看到了这一点。这就像观察人类。我们说人类，人类是辉煌的。我们有爱因斯坦。我们有贝多芬。我们有毕加索。
We have, you know, all these incredible things that humans have done. But not every human can, you know, even solve an algebra question, okay, can, you know, sing any kind of a tune can hold a paintbrush straight, okay? But we look at those individuals and say, well, they could do it so humans are capable. And so that's what I'm trying to tell you. people, you know. I mean, if Athena had been my first subject, we might not be talking today, okay? And that's not to say that she isn't smart, but she's just not, her personality is such that she just doesn't care that much about showing us that level of smartness, whereas Alex and Griffin really did. And it's not a male-female thing, because I sometimes work with two other grays.
我们有，你知道，人类所做的所有这些不可思议的事情。但并不是每个人类都能，你知道，甚至解决一个代数问题，好吗？能，你知道，唱任何一种曲调，能把画笔拿直，好吗？但我们看着那些个体并说，嗯，它们能做到，所以人类是有能力的。这就是我试图告诉人们的。我的意思是，如果雅典娜是我的第一个研究对象，我们今天可能就不会在这里谈话了，好吗？这并不是说她不聪明，但她的个性使她只是不太在乎向我们展示那种程度的聪明，而亚历克斯和格里芬确实在乎。而且这不是男女差异，因为我有时会和另外两只灰鹦鹉一起工作。
they belong to colleagues who worked in my lab for a while, and they have their own grays. They now live on the Cape, and we sometimes use their birds because they worked in the lab. They understand experimental design, and they understand they have to send me every videotape of their bird. Even if their bird is acting stupid, they know they have to send it, and they don't have to follow the protocol exactly. And their bird pepper has done a lot of the same things that Griffin has done, as has the other bird Franco. So it's not a male-female thing. It's a personality thing. What does research on bird
它们属于在我的实验室工作过一段时间的同事，它们有自己的灰鹦鹉。它们现在住在海角，我们有时会使用它们的鸟，因为它们在实验室工作过。它们了解实验设计，它们了解它们必须把鸟的每一盘录像带都寄给我。即使它们的鸟表现得很笨，它们也知道它们必须寄过来，而且它们不必完全遵循实验方案。它们的鸟佩珀已经做了很多格里芬做过的事情，另一只鸟佛朗哥也是如此。所以这不是男女差异。这是个性差异。鸟类研究
intelligence tell us about intelligence more broadly, whether that's with other animals or with humans? Well, it does talk about the evolution of intelligence. When you think about the fact that humans and birds have been separated by over 300 million years of evolution, okay, go back to the dinosaurs essentially. So we've had this convergent evolution, and we can show that these totally different, you know, species have certain similarities in common, and that makes us think about how many other species might be intelligent
智力告诉我们关于更广泛的智力，无论是与其他动物还是与人类？嗯，它确实谈到了智力的进化。当你想到人类和鸟类已经被超过3亿年的进化分开了，好吗，基本上回到恐龙时代。所以我们有了这种趋同进化，我们可以证明这些完全不同的，你知道，物种有某些共同的相似之处，这让我们思考还有多少其他物种可能是聪明的
and do this kind of work if they were studied appropriately. It also suggests that we should realize that not every brain has to look human-like or even primate-like. I talked about these seven centers of vocal learning in the bird brain, but if you just look at a bird brain, it just looks like a blob of jello. If you compare it to our brain that has all the, they're called gyrion sulky, but all the ups and downs and curves and stuff, you know what I'm talking about when you look at the picture of a brain.
如果它们被适当地研究，就能做这种工作。这也表明我们应该意识到，并非每个大脑都必须看起来像人类，甚至像灵长类动物。我谈到了鸟类大脑中这七个发声学习中心，但如果你只是看一个鸟类大脑，它看起来就像一团果冻。如果你把它和我们的大脑相比，我们的大脑有所有的，它们被称为脑回和脑沟，但所有的起伏和曲线之类的东西，你知道我在说什么，当你看着大脑图片时。
A bird brain just looked like a blob of protoblop, blob of jello. But there are areas in that brain that correspond to the same areas in our brain. They're cortical areas. They don't look cortical, but they act like our cortex. And the same with other different areas. So it suggests that we should look far and wide for the types of intelligence that are out there. When you first started doing this work in the 1970s, you were one of a handful of people who were doing this kind of research. How has the field developed over the ensuing decades? By leaps and bounds. I mean, my first
鸟类大脑看起来就像一团原浆，一团果冻。但大脑中有一些区域对应于我们大脑中的相同区域。它们是皮层区域。它们看起来不像皮层，但它们的作用就像我们的皮层。其他不同区域也是如此。所以这表明我们应该广泛地寻找那里存在的各种智力。当你第一次在20世纪70年代做这项工作时，你是少数做这种研究的人之一。这个领域在随后的几十年里是如何发展的？突飞猛进。我的意思是，我的第一个
grand proposal came back literally asking me what I was smoking. I mean, this was the 70s. I mean, and a little aside from that, I met the person many years later who had written that and he apologized. But the point was that people really didn't believe it. Because, I mean, there was no neurobiology. It wasn't until 2005 that people. really recognize the similarities between the avian and the primate brain. But there are so many groups now who are looking at avian intelligence across the world. And it's really exciting to see how this has changed. We now have a society called comparative cognition. But it's only 30 years old. There was 20 years there where we were still trying to make our way in the field and get people to create us seriously.
拨款申请书回来时，字面上问我抽了什么。我的意思是，那是70年代。我的意思是，除此之外，多年后我遇到了写那份报告的人，他道歉了。但重点是人们真的不相信。因为，我的意思是，没有神经生物学。直到2005年，人们才真正认识到鸟类大脑和灵长类大脑之间的相似之处。但现在有这么多团队在世界各地研究鸟类智力。看到这种变化真的很令人兴奋。我们现在有一个叫做比较认知的协会。但它只有30岁。有20年的时间，我们还在努力在这一领域开辟道路，让人们认真对待我们。
So do you feel vindicated as a researcher or are there still a lot of skeptical scientists out there? A combination of both. I mean, there are still some people who sort of go, well, yeah, you know, maybe there are a couple of birds that are smart, but yeah, you know. And then there, you know, the majority of people do seem to appreciate that we need to look at all the creatures with whom we share this universe and start appreciating what they might be able to do. And again, it's not, you know, we have to realize that, I mean, what I do by comparing them to young children is to make it clear to humans how smart they are because humans only understand that kind of comparison. But if you think about the kinds of things that animals do in the wild and survive in the wild and all the techniques they use and all the different abilities they have, I mean, a lot of animals here. notes that we can't possibly hear, either high or low. Okay, elephants have what we call infrasound.
那么你作为一名研究人员感到平反了吗？还是仍然有很多怀疑的科学家？两者兼而有之。我的意思是，仍然有一些人，你知道，也许有几只鸟很聪明，但，你知道。然后，你知道，大多数人似乎确实意识到我们需要观察我们共享这个宇宙的所有生物，并开始欣赏它们可能能够做的事情。同样，这不是，你知道，我们必须意识到，我的意思是，我通过将它们与幼儿进行比较所做的事情，是为了向人类清楚地表明它们有多聪明，因为人类只理解那种比较。但如果你想想动物在野外所做的各种事情，在野外生存，它们使用的所有技术以及它们拥有的所有不同能力，我的意思是，很多动物在这里。我们根本听不到的音符，无论是高音还是低音。好吗，大象有我们所说的次声波。
Dolphins use ultrasound, okay? Vision, birds see in the ultraviolet. They see so many more different colors than we do. That, you know, we can't even imagine what it's like. You know, you think about animals that have sensing small degrees of temperature sensing, and that's how they get their prey. Okay. You know, that track one another.
海豚使用超声波，对吧？视觉方面，鸟类能看到紫外线。它们看到的颜色比我们多得多。那种感觉，你知道，我们甚至无法想象那是什么样子。你知道，想想那些能感知微小温度变化的动物，它们就是靠这个来捕获猎物的。对吧。你知道，它们追踪彼此的方式。
Just think about how well your dog sense things. Okay. And we are, you know, we're totally incapable of doing that type of thing. So we need to appreciate these animals, not just because they can do human-like tasks, but, you know, and what's the technical term is their own vault. They're, their environment, their everything that surrounds them and their way they see the world. and not just see the world, but the way they sense the world in all different ways. In the interest of full disclosure, I have to out myself as someone who had pet cockatiels for many decades.
想想你的狗感知事物有多敏锐。对吧。而我们，你知道，完全没有那种能力。所以我们需要欣赏这些动物，不仅仅是因为它们能完成类似人类的任务，而是因为，你知道，用专业术语来说，它们有自己的世界。它们的环境，它们周围的一切，以及它们看待世界的方式。不仅是看待世界，还有它们以各种不同方式感知世界的方式。为了坦诚起见，我得承认自己几十年来一直养着玄凤鹦鹉。
My last one died a couple of years ago at the age of, I think he was about 35. And he even made a few appearances on this podcast because he was noisy. But given how smart parrots are, how do you feel about people keeping them as pets? Is it fair to the parrot? Well, that's, again, another really good question. And I answer this by asking the people who want to keep parrots, what's their lifestyle? So, you know, somebody comes up to me after I give a talk and says, I want a parrot, just like Alex. And I say, well, what do you do?
我的最后一只鹦鹉几年前去世了，当时它大约35岁。它甚至在这个播客中露过几次面，因为它很吵。但考虑到鹦鹉有多聪明，你觉得人们把它们当作宠物养合适吗？这对鹦鹉公平吗？嗯，这又是一个非常好的问题。我通过询问那些想养鹦鹉的人来回答这个问题：他们的生活方式是什么样的？所以，你知道，我做完演讲后有人走过来对我说，我想要一只像亚历克斯那样的鹦鹉。我就问，那你平时做什么？
Oh, well, you know, I have three kids and I take them all, you know, to all their different activities. And I work at hours a day and have a two-hour commute. And before they say anything else, I say, get a picture of a parrot and put it on your refrigerator. Okay. because pirates are flock animals. They, you know, a single bird in the wild is a dead bird. They can't eat and look for predators at the same time. They communicate with their flock members.
哦，嗯，你知道，我有三个孩子，我得带他们参加各种不同的活动。我每天工作八小时，还要通勤两小时。在他们说其他话之前，我会说，去拍一张鹦鹉的照片贴在你的冰箱上。对吧。因为鹦鹉是群居动物。它们，你知道，在野外，落单的鸟就是死鸟。它们不可能一边吃东西一边观察捕食者。它们需要与群体成员交流。
They preen one another. They interact with one another. You can't do that. And then they say, well, get two birds. And I say, and how close to you are you to your freshman college roommate who was chosen for you, you know? Then I get somebody who says, you know, I work at home most of the time. and I don't travel very much.
它们会互相梳理羽毛。它们会互相互动。你做不到这一点。然后他们会说，那养两只鸟吧。我就说，那你和你大学一年级时被分配给你的室友关系有多亲密呢？然后我会遇到有人说，你知道，我大部分时间都在家工作，而且我不怎么出差。
And I say, you know, that could work. It's not that you have to interact with the bird 24-7 or even, you know, 12 hours a day the way we do with our birds. But, you know, they like to have the companionship. They want to sit on the perch near you. That doesn't mean you probably experience this. That doesn't mean you have to be scratching their head all the time or interacting with them all the time. But just the fact that they can see you, they feel safe because you're with them and things like that are really important to them. They need cages. I mean, a cockatiel, it's easy because you don't know you to huge cage.
我就说，你知道，那可能行得通。并不是说你必须24小时全天候与鸟互动，甚至不需要像我们对待自己的鸟那样每天互动12小时。但是，你知道，它们喜欢陪伴。它们想坐在你身边的栖木上。这并不意味着——你可能也经历过——这并不意味着你必须一直抓挠它们的头或者一直与它们互动。但只要它们能看到你，它们就会感到安全，因为你和它们在一起，诸如此类的事情对它们来说非常重要。它们需要笼子。我是说，玄凤鹦鹉很容易养，因为你不需要一个巨大的笼子。
But think about, you know, most parents, they need to be able to, you know, stretch their wings, okay, fully, all right? They need to be able to glide a little bit, all right? They need those kinds of experiences. You wouldn't take a six-year-old child and put it in a playpen for eight hours a day with a couple of snacks and some, you know, some games and say, here, you know, that's your life, which is. what we do to some of these birds. So, you know, I tell people to really evaluate their lifestyle before. And again, if they do decide to get a bird, make sure they get one that's been hand-raised. And if at all possible, to have been, you know, at least weaned by the parents before being taken away, because that's another issue that we're finding is really important.
但想想看，你知道，大多数鹦鹉，它们需要能够，你知道，完全伸展翅膀，对吧？它们需要能够滑翔一点，对吧？它们需要那种体验。你不会把一个六岁的孩子关在游戏围栏里，每天八小时，只给一点零食和一些游戏，然后说，给你，这就是你的生活，而这正是我们对其中一些鸟所做的事情。所以，你知道，我告诉人们在决定养鸟之前要真正评估他们的生活方式。再说一次，如果他们确实决定养一只鸟，一定要确保它是人工喂养的。如果可能的话，最好在被带走之前由亲鸟断奶，因为这是我们发现的另一个非常重要的问题。
So just to wrap up, what's next on your horizon? What are you working on? What are the big questions that you still want to answer? Well, one of the big ones is this visual working memory that I've talked about mentioned briefly. So it's basically a shell game on steroids. And what we do is you take the hardest of the tasks, you have four little colored pom-pums, you put little black cups over all four of them, and then you start doing swaps. And after you've done four swaps, then you pick up one color pop-pum, and you say, find the yellow one. So you have to have tracked all four of them.
那么总结一下，你接下来的计划是什么？你正在研究什么？你还有哪些想要回答的大问题？嗯，其中一个大问题就是我刚才简要提到的视觉工作记忆。这基本上就是一种加强版的“猜杯游戏”。我们所做的是，你采用最难的任务，你有四个彩色绒球，你在所有四个绒球上盖上黑色小杯子，然后开始交换位置。交换四次后，你拿起一个彩色绒球，然后说，找到黄色的那个。所以你必须追踪所有四个绒球。
Griffin beat out six to eight-year-old kids completely on this task. He beat out Harvard undergraduates until we got to the four cups and four pom-poms. Then he cratered some, but he was so bored at that point that I'm not sure, you know, it was really fair. But he did, I mean, he was really good on, he beat out the Harvard undergraduates on four cups up to two, swaps. And then on three swaps, he fell down a little bit, and in four swaps, he had some more trouble. So now we're replicating this because we thought, hmm, when we gave it to the Harvard undergraduates, though, we wanted to make sure they weren't using what we call verbal rehearsal. So if you know the color labels, while we're doing the swaps, you can be thinking in your head,
格里芬在这个任务上完全击败了六到八岁的孩子。他击败了哈佛大学的本科生，直到我们增加到四个杯子和四个绒球。那时他表现有些下滑，但我不太确定，你知道，这是否真的公平。但他确实，我是说，他在四个杯子和两次交换的任务中表现非常好，击败了哈佛本科生。然后在三次交换时，他稍微有点失误，在四次交换时，他遇到了一些困难。所以现在我们正在重复这个实验，因为我们想，嗯，当我们给哈佛本科生做这个测试时，我们想确保他们没有使用我们所谓的“言语复述”。所以如果你知道颜色标签，在我们进行交换时，你可以在脑子里想，
red, blue, yellow, green, red, blue, green yellow, you know, tracking the swaps. But Griffin knows the labels for his colors. It's possible he was doing that. Because the undergraduates, we asked them to say two plus two is four, two plus two is four, things like that while they were watching the swaps to prevent that verbal rehearsal. So we're now replicating it with little objects he can't label. And so we're up to three little objects, they're little leaf shape things, three objects and no swaps, and he's been 100% up to there. And we're just about to keep going. And the problem right now is his arthritis has kicked in, and it's really hard for him to, you know, to move his body to choose which one, that's when he pecks to tell us which one he wants.
红、蓝、黄、绿，红、蓝、绿、黄，你知道，追踪交换过程。但格里芬知道他颜色的标签。他有可能在这样做。因为对于本科生，我们要求他们一边看交换一边说“二加二等于四，二加二等于四”之类的话，以防止那种言语复述。所以我们现在正在用他无法标记的小物体重复这个实验。目前我们用三个小物体，它们是小叶子形状的东西，三个物体且不交换，他到目前为止准确率是100%。我们正准备继续进行。现在的问题是他的关节炎发作了，他很难，你知道，移动身体来选择哪一个，那是他通过啄来告诉我们他想要哪一个的时候。
So it's really hard to get him to choose right now. Sounds like you need to take him to Times Square to play three-card Monty. There you go. Well, Dr. Pepperberg, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really fascinating. Thank you. Oh, thank you so much for having me. This has been fun.
所以现在让他做出选择真的很难。听起来你需要带他去时代广场玩“三张牌赌局”。你说得对。好吧，佩珀伯格博士，我想感谢你今天参加我的节目。这真的非常引人入胜。谢谢。哦，非常感谢你邀请我。这很有趣。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wyneman. Thank you for listening. for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀恩曼制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。